(mellow relaxing music)
- [Narrator] It's Thanksgiving;
turkey, stuffing, mashed potatoes,
but the one thing that
has always stood out
is a bit of a head scratcher:
sweet potato casserole, mmm.
We're pretty sure sweet
potatoes and marshmallows
weren't at the original Thanksgiving.
So what happened?
Sweet potatoes have been around forever.
And marshmallows, this sticky, gooey mess
actually comes from a plant
and has been around since ancient Egypt.
A delicacy only pharaohs could eat.
Okay, fast forward to the 20th century.
Marshmallows were a big deal,
expensive, and essentially
the Cristal of sweet treats.
Not only that, but they
were even hand made.
Marshmallows became a mainstay
for highfalutin housewives.
See, back then, housewives
would have to make whipped cream
or even meringue by hand,
but the marshmallows
were a modern time saver.
The first recipe that
paired sweet potatoes
and marshmallows appeared in 1918
in a trade journal, cleverly
named Sweet Potatoes and Yams.
As marshmallows grew in popularity
and began being mass produced,
more and more recipes
began implementing them
as an everyday ingredient.
Nowadays, marshmallows are generally
reserved for campfires and hot chocolate,
and this nontraditional/
traditional favorite.
Whether you like your sweet potatoes
a la marshmallow or plain,
happy Thanksgiving!
(mid-tempo relaxing music)